thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a gossipy
wild ride with Stevo the boys and I
weigh in on all the juiciest scandals
going on and man is it just a lot of fun
I don't even feel bad about it but maybe
I should and we're here in London
England where maybe you saw me jump off
the Tower of London Bridge because woof
did that get some coverage and I got the
whole crew out here extended family I
mean it's a big deal going on and we
just finished recording this episode so
man enjoy it and wish me luck yeah dude
let's get to it
ladies and gentlemen me and the boys the
gorgeous Paul Briskey Scott Randolph and
the prison pocket expert skinny Vinny
cheers all right we are in London
England
um just a few days removed from getting
a whole lot of press for jumping off the
Tower of London Bridge man what a day
that was it was it was an epic day
um technically it's not called the Tower
of London Bridge it's called Tower
Bridge
but oh so the London Bridge Is Something
Completely Different yeah what's the
like London Bridge is falling down like
I thought that's what you jumped off of
I don't know it was maybe it fell down
actually it's probably not made the song
it was called that in like the 1800s or
maybe the one they're talking about
London Bridge
and this is exciting because it's the
first time we have had uh like Joe Rogan
uh
internet component where we can actually
dig up yeah stuff and this podcast will
be released uh roughly 24 hours after it
was recorded so let's talk current
events I want to say that Joan hill
didn't do [__] wrong I have not even
seen the text yeah I mean it seems like
the consensus is that like what did he
do wrong he I mean dude he I read his
texts they weren't they weren't bad he
was like look
he said if you want to uh like hang out
with dudes or put like uh post pictures
in your bikini or like have like
relationships with unhealthy chicks like
uh then I'm not the partner for you easy
yeah but then what's up with the whole
you can't post pictures in your bikini
no I think he she can post pictures in
her bikini but like not straight up like
thong shots or if like her on the beach
in a thong but if she's like surfing and
that's what she does for work I think
that was the idea I mean it sounds like
Jonah Hill is insecure I think it's
weird to say like you can't hang out
with dudes or like don't post that on
your Instagram yeah it's pretty normal
that's pretty normal I always thought
that was weird I still think it's weird
but it doesn't make him like a piece of
[__] you should like normal for a like a
chicken relationship to go hang out with
dudes no it sounds like it's normal for
guys to say don't hang out with dudes
I've always found that really weird and
I don't give a [__] yeah but it's more
normal for sure chicks to tell their
dudes not to hang out with chicks and
I'm very sensitive to that because with
my checkered past and sexual addiction
like I I don't need to be you don't even
put yourself in any situation where that
might happen that if I'm ever going to
be alone with a girl I let Lux know like
hey I'm Gonna Be Alone with a girl yeah
but I've noticed when that like you'll
FaceTime bucks while you're in the room
yeah I think that's appropriate yeah you
see Paul isn't like that Paul doesn't
have it the Paul's a hippie Paul's had
sex with like three people
would you be upset if your chick had
she's like oh I'm just gonna grab lunch
with my friend John I mean it all
depends the kind of like they're John's
a hot dude he's a hot like straight dude
yeah I would feel a little uncomfortable
okay well that just has to do with micro
security
Vinnie how about when you know she's
gonna [__] him and the camera and the
millions of people are going to watch it
on browsers
um
I wouldn't feel that comfortable with
um I've gone through this in my head
over and over and over again I mean
you've gone through it in real life are
you talking about Adam 22 or Vinnie
Vinnie 22. okay I just I just threw you
away no no it's great and I it's not
like an atom 2 222 situation because
this happened before we even knew each
other so let's catch people what is what
exactly are we talking about talking
about you're a girl my girl Otto oh
you're talking about this
22.
no no no
um she did a scene with Kieran Lee a
very popular uh male porn star and this
was like late last year but we've known
each other yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
uh he's got a wife a couple kids
um and I didn't know this about her and
when we were in Australia when we were
like seriously talking for a while
um she's like okay I have to tell you
something it's like really eating me I
uh I didn't think I was gonna like you
this much and I just want you to I want
to be the one to tell you before you
find out and she told me and at first I
was very like very shocked and I think I
I talked to you about it I talked to
Isaac about it when he walked into the
bus pale white yeah yeah are you good
dude yeah yeah and uh but since then
I've come to terms with it and I'm
totally okay with it has she expressed
any desire to do more uh porn mainstream
stuff no mainstream stuff like no what's
mainstream stuff like Brazzers oh that's
mainstream for sure
like NBC
so she is interested in doing really CD
underground stuff I wouldn't call it CD
right I mean yeah underground like with
you or with yeah other people too yeah
with me and only with me only with you
yeah
um I've asked her I've asked her if like
do you ever think you're gonna go and do
another scene because she made a lot of
money doing it and uh she's like no I
don't want to I promise like I would
tell you I would totally be honest and
so I believe would you be upset if she
wanted to bring another girl into the
mix
I don't know dude I've never really had
that that situation happen before I
don't know how I'd feel
um I can say that I don't think there's
any such thing as a healthy relationship
where you're doing threesomes I I agree
with you yeah and I don't know and I
think I just have a lot of insecurities
and I'm a jealous person in general
somebody who's jealous of the other girl
I think I would be oh yeah yeah I don't
know I don't know I've it's never
happened I'm sure some people are doing
it and being okay with it but yeah it's
like so risky it's not worth it like if
you're in a healthy relationship would
you have a threesome with your fiance
I'd be so scared like I I would my I
would very heavily lean towards no just
because like it's bound to cause an
issue somebody always gets the short end
of the stick it's impossible for that
not to be the case and so even if the
the couple is uh you know gets away with
it you're still doing harm to somebody
um yeah that that's not good so let's
talk about Adam 22. he's all in the news
with the do you think that that was
Annette L for adam22 or do you buy what
he says that it was great for his wife's
career as well as his career I mean
certainly got a lot of uh I mean it's
definitely I believe it's definitely
great for their careers I mean to each
their own you know if like if he's cool
with it
is there such thing as bad press
um yes
is that bad press I it's not a
cancelable offense no no no but like I
mean even if it's negative towards Adam
or whatever letting his uh Lena [__]
another dude but like is it is it bad
for business or is it good for business
no it's definitely good for business
because I guarantee their plug Talk
podcast is just and once she releases
that video if she hasn't already it's
gonna blow the [__] up yeah him
explaining the crib Mack what he did was
hilarious yeah you guys had to keep
bringing up crib Mack who's that 55 dude
Mac is a guy who's on he's like a no
jumper kind of like side character yeah
and he's this dude and he just like he
hosts a show he's like a legitimate crib
right okay and he's just really funny
he's just really a character which is
kind of what he came on a roller coaster
was the best thing I've ever seen he's
just super funny like now I've heard
that uh like the the no jumper like kind
of
people have been defecting and leaving
no jumper and doing their own thing and
that it bodes poorly for for the no
jumper brand
I like Adam 22. yeah what was the vibe
when you did the uh podcast yeah it was
great I um
we did a double upload yep
um it was it was really interesting too
because I was like yeah you know you got
your um YouTube uh Creator Studio
Creator studio app dashboard and it's
just like shows you all of your numbers
your last 10 videos how they rank and I
just screenshot it like Square what do I
carry and I'll I'll let them see all of
our analytics and uh right away he sent
me his
you can learn a lot from your analytics
and I'll tell you if they look good why
aren't you making money off of it that's
what ship stations for baby now let me
tell you that my Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole thanks to ship station has
done so spectacularly well that my
notoriously successful CEO father is
coming out of retirement to try to sell
the brand he thinks that we could pull a
Rob Dyrdek move because we've been
killing it with ship station and if you
can build an audience online then it is
time to monetize that baby and ship
station is the way to do it it's an easy
to use interface that brings together
all your different methods of selling
Etsy eBay Amazon your own website
doesn't even matter and it also brings
into the interface all the different
ways of shipping FedEx UPS United States
Postal Service and it gives you the best
rates that are available rates that are
normally reserved for Fortune 500
companies you can get that when you're
shipping with ship station and when
you're using it man you get an order the
label prints out you slap it on the box
stick the hot sauce in there and off it
goes and you can get a two month
60-day free trial with ship station if
you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo one more time it's
shipstation.com use the promo code Stevo
for your risk-free 60-day free trial it
is time to make ship happen now let's
get back to it
and um at the time our podcasts were
really pretty on par with each other wow
I think that
um like the the low end and the high end
of typical views for one of us started
lower and went higher but it was the
range was very similar and I thought man
how cool you know yeah
um it also helped us I think to um
you know I think double uploads just
generally help if you've got like super
super fans they want to hear both and
you drive traffic to each other I had a
great experience with them nice but yeah
with him and his his chick doing porn
now with other because they've done porn
for a long time just the two of them no
or like other jokes would come in the
plug Talk podcast is a podcast where
they would talk for 45 minutes
that's got to be the most fast forwarded
45 minutes
um now here here's another example about
how did somebody gets the short end of
the stick and it's probably not a nice
thing to say but
um I I've seen their Instagram where
they show all their their guests on the
plug podcast and there has not been one
guessed that was hotter than his wife
did they have like Angela White
um they did have Angela yeah
I mean I've only seen hotter chicks no
no no dude don't ask me yeah I don't
know that many porn stars like I don't
think I could name I'm stuck there when
uh when we just saw the the guy who
hammered uh Vinny's girlfriend
I don't recognize anybody in porn
anymore it's been so long since I swore
up it's like people talking about Molly
and you're like I never even like I
missed that whole boat yeah it was just
yeah it was not Molly there's a lot of
things that I missed and thank god
um fentanyl I would yeah it's gonna be
out of the mix on something you can
bring up any guest that's been on plug
talk and I submit that not one of them
will be hotter than lean of the plug
well okay who's the guy that had sex
with Lena is he hotter than adam22
um I mean
BBC
well you just gotta turn off safe search
go over to the right
safe searches like if you search it's
not going to show you now now save
search is off now it's not going to
Blossom search on [__] no whose computer
is that definitely not Vinnies there we
go okay
that's the biggest dick I've ever seen
in your life
so it's not like necessarily a handsome
guy but he looks like he'd beat Adam you
guys got a hammer
[Music]
this is more important than I've watched
in years
yeah we should change maybe we should
turn safe search back on yeah
uh and we should also be careful about
uh can can using the word porn and you
know like can we switch it up to the ynw
Melly case are you guys following that
you are so fascinated by every time we
see you you're just like you see what's
going on with this it just sends me now
because I'm on YouTube shorts and like
that's all that possible people don't
know what's going on give us a little
yeah
who is ynw Melly I honestly don't even
know I'm just so fascinated with this
guy in the court case and it started
when he got so excited when he got a
honey bun when he was in interrogation
I'm like what the [__] but I guess what
happened was okay so there's
interrogation footage of the cops
bringing him a honey bun yeah they're
like would you like a honey bun they go
to get it he's just in there dancing
he's stoked as [__] and I'm like who is
this guy and it turns out I don't know
much about him but I'm I'm curious to
see NW what does ynw stand for I don't
know there's a bunch of them
so it's like a crew kind of like YSL
yeah I guess from Florida and uh and
after I I allegedly there's four guys in
the car and uh the two guys in the front
got murdered or I know sorry that's him
dancing with the honey bun okay well let
me let me ask you this what the hell is
he doing talking to the cops in the
interrogation room how can he be a
gangster if he didn't say go I'm not
saying anything give me my lawyer take
me back to myself I think he was maybe
I mean they they had a terms I don't
have no idea we had a honey bun
no I don't know much but I guess there's
the two guys in the front seat died and
then uh they drove the guys to the
hospital or whatever they said it was a
drive-by that happened but like the guys
that uh turned him into the hospital
they had like a fresh pair of clothes on
it but they had gunpowder on their hands
so there's him and some other guy are
the suspects in this case so what about
it is so fascinating to you you're
saying that they shot the victims and
then took them to the hospital so
allegedly what the prosecutors are
saying is like the the bullets had to
have come from inside the vehicle and
the two guys in the back are saying it
came from a drive-by
and so they don't have a murder weapon
but I'm just so fascinated in this guy
because when I look more into him he
says he has six personalities and they
had footage of him like after the
murders in a parking lot dancing and I'm
just like
and then you hear a song everywhere on
on like YouTube shorts oh is this one of
the ones where they're uh using his
lyrics yeah
against him that makes sense to me if
the lyrics and cleared information that
only the killer would know yeah or like
it shouldn't be like your only evidence
but if you're confessing if you confess
on a recording that's evidence and like
just because you have it to a beat it's
still a confession but I thought lyrics
Don't hold up in the court of law I mean
I don't think they should be like your
only evidence but it's especially yeah
like Steve's saying if you know
something that like only the killer
would know
all right so uh I'm just fascinated that
this is a case where the victims were
shot and then taken to the hospital by
the shooters
they don't know if they are the shooters
that's the whole thing
would you really take somebody to the
hospital right after you shot them
that's like oh man
crimes because they're like do you think
he did it and then I was like well does
he have a past and then I start reading
about his list of charges that he's had
since he was a kid and you're like [__]
dude but if somebody drove by and shot
the people in the front seat the people
in the back seat would have maybe been
shooting back at that car meaning there
is gun residue in the car that doesn't
mean they shot the people in the front
seat I guess it shoots the driver of the
car that you're in I don't know it's
like
I I don't know and I and and I'd be
fasting fascinated to see if he got out
uh I mean he I guess what he did he he
shot at a cop or something spent a year
in jail and then he got out and he shot
at three kids from his high school then
went to I mean his real name is demons
his last name is you know his last name
is demons that's kind of cool yeah so
super cool yeah wow
if he was to be found guilty death
penalty death penalty but uh like what
if he's like I guess the first rapper
that might get sentenced to the death
penalty even but what if they uh if he
what's it called when you when you say
you're crazy
um plead Insanity yeah is that why he's
saying that he has six personalities no
he said it before on like podcasts and
and uh yeah I don't know
I mean
I I okay
I kind of want him to get off but I also
like if he did it in no way but like
then why do you want to I don't know
because he made he's like makes good
music I don't know I haven't even heard
a song by him you've heard it for sure
all right
um I watched enough True Crime stuff
that I'm just still very disappointed in
him talking to the cops honey bun or no
honey bun I'm just when anyone talks to
the cops like we watch these things it's
like just shut up say let me talk am I
arrested then I want a lawyer that's all
you need to say but everyone just do you
watch those constitutional Auditors and
they go up to the place
sometimes I was like what he's like
excuse me what's your name what's your
badge number yeah but those dudes are
kind of like douchey and annoying for
sure I'm more interested in like
interrogation footage Steve got me
really into like JCS in these channels
yeah where it's like breaking down
interrogations and like yeah you know
how they kind of get at somebody but all
they have to say is like yeah I want a
lawyer and like show's over yeah there's
nothing you can do in the interrogation
room that's going to help you
yeah except for saying nothing even if
you're completely have you ever been in
an interrogation room no have you been
an interior you've been interrogated by
uh homicide detectives but I don't know
if it was interrogating but but I was uh
very close to a murder like a brutal
double murder and uh
you heard that right a double murder and
being close to something like that can
be a lot for somebody to go through and
that is why I'm glad this episode is
brought to you by better help you see
when things are weighing on you
stressing you out man it messes with
your mental health and therapy is the
key to breaking all that down piece by
piece and improving your mental health I
do it and I do it with better help
that's better
h-e-l-p.com and if you go to
betterhelp.com
Stevo then you can get 10 off your first
month and I'm telling you man they've
got a whole network of fully licensed
professional therapists and they've
matched like three million people with
therapists and people are thriving
because this is the way to better Mental
Health health I particularly focus on my
relationship with Lux okay they say you
want to fix the roof before it rains
right that's how I approach therapy fix
the roof before it rains make sure that
we're in a good place and protect this
relationship that's so important to me
and whatever it is that you want to
protect you're going to do a much better
job if you go to betterhelp.com
Stevo and enjoy 10 off your first month
I hope you do that and I wish you well
now let's get back to it yeah it was in
1996 on the campus of the University of
Miami this is when I was sleeping in the
athletic apartments with the uh the
University of Miami uh dive team you
were there for like two weeks there's
the athletic apartments and so there was
a
a uh man what's the name of the football
player yeah football player and his
girlfriend were both just bludgeoned to
death yeah but Marlon Barnes yep and she
was found dead at 7 30 a.m and I was
sleeping like like in the like down one
level and you know one floor down and
one apartment adjacent
so they had to interview me and uh and I
was like oh I got home at like two in
the morning I was hammered and they were
like I'm gonna drink this cup
yeah
it was uh and he was a football player
for UNM and what you went into the
station or no no no they just uh it was
it was um at the scene of the murders
whoa jeez what kind of questions did
they ask you they were just like where
were you last night and I was like oh I
was super hammered I got back here at
like you know two two in the morning or
like three in the morning or something
and they were like all right then you
didn't do it I don't know dude I have we
even talked about who's in your lap yeah
okay
um I have a dog on my lap and um it like
it appears to be a very docile good dog
but it's not it's not
um here in the UK I um you know it's
just wanted to foster a dog for the
duration of the tour we went to a couple
shelters and and it was no go and then
we found this shelter in whole England
that's h-u-l-l where this lady just runs
a shelter out of her house she said that
at the moment she had 92 animals in her
house how big is her house uh I mean
most of the animals were like birds and
would you say birds uh like
lizards rabbits what did it smell like
in there uh we didn't go inside she just
she just brought this dog outside and
this dog is not good with other dogs or
cats or young children now I haven't
seen it have a problem with children but
um
apparently those are those are dice that
you do not want to roll that's a pretty
safe assumption yeah and um and her name
is well she's had many names it's like
on her passport where she was born in
Spain they they wrote the name brownie
the lady in Hall who had her in that
house with 92 animals named her Skyler
um she was on my uh like on my lap while
I got my my pickled onion monster Munch
tattoo and so then we started calling
her pickle but um she proved to be such
an absolute Terror attacking every dog
she possibly can no matter its size
um and she's just such a nightmare that
we started calling her tazzy for
Tasmanian devil she does bear
resemblance to a little resemblance yeah
I see it yeah and it's gonna be sad
because she's like pretty bonded with me
at this point and so then and I can't
bring her home because we've got dogs
and cats and
um so uh yeah she might be going back to
the lady who runs the shelter out of her
out of her house but we filmed that
video I mean we can find a home for her
yeah maybe anybody listening in England
right now who doesn't have a dog or a
cat or a kid maybe announce it at the
show
uh she'll already be gone by the taping
of the show and the taping of the show
The Bucket List special wow wow wow he's
coming up pretty exciting yeah a couple
days away not including all the people
who I flew out to just be here
um it's a 185
000 shoot in the theater just shooting
in the theater is that typical like do
most specials cost somewhere around
there
uh I know that on the night of the shoot
for the gnarly special it was like 125
um and that uh that you know what it
actually might include all the
post-production I think that's to get to
the deliverables so it's 185 000 for
shooting it and all of the uh
post-production editing now does a does
a percentage of that go to The Venue as
well or is it I'm sure it covers all
expenses yeah there's a little bit of a
fee
um for like you pay you pay a certain
amount to a theater to rent the theater
in order to do the show and you
definitely pay more to the theater to be
able to film The Show for a special but
dude like I'm so ready for this man and
thanks to this guy right here the
gorgeous Paul Briskey I mean like we've
just we've tirelessly studied it
workshopped it come up with every little
option like oh let's try this let's try
that and uh man I just am really excited
about it yeah it's been so fun like
tweaking on [__] and then because you
get like the next night you can just try
the new way and it's like oh that didn't
work okay let's try something new or
something so it's it's like pretty
immediate results you get to see every
piece of this projects I mean dude what
do we spend on the opening sequence with
the helicopter
like 70 to 90. it's way too way more
than that really I think so I thought I
thought that was over over a hundred
thousand dollar a day
um I need to double check but I I mean
the helicopter was a lot
yeah I've been dude everything was a lot
that's the most though right of all the
bits the helicopter for sure yeah the
taping of the show is the most and the
helicopter
um was was skyjacking expensive no
vasectomy Olympics was certainly
expensive yeah because that was all we
had to fly everybody out there
um Batman whatever it's just like and
dude the production design
do I say on this what the production
design is
if you want yeah I give a little tease
of it sure because this is coming out
before it maybe yeah do it dude okay but
Lux is the production designer I told
her that I think the most masterful
badass
comedy special that I've seen in a long
time was Jew by R.A shaffir and and one
of the most impressive things about it
was that uh he performed in front of
like hundreds maybe a thousand lit
candles
I was just like dude it was so ambitious
it was so rad like how do I do something
like that with the production design but
first stop because uh you know it's sort
of a of a love story and and the bucket
list items like the this it's the show
is a story about how me doing all the
things on the on my bucket list like
impacted my relationship mostly
negatively
um so I thought like roses but roses
would just look dumb and then luck says
well dude it's a multimedia show like uh
bringing together you know your your
video production into your live
performance so why not have like a
mountain like a wall of television sets
like old school TVs old school TVs I'm
like oh my God that's so genius
so she's literally she came up with the
idea she
found
hundreds of old-school TV sets from the
80s and 90s a lot of garage sales she's
been going to the the the this wall of
TVs behind me is seven feet tall and 24
feet wide with islands in the front for
the crossettes there's even more just
the wall of TVs behind me weighs more
than 1.5 metric tons and every single
one of the TVs comprising that wall
totally works and will be displaying
images and videos while like the it's
all going on it's pretty epic dude it's
unbelievably epic yeah like I I can't
even stand it it's just like every
little piece of this show
like we've gone to like ridiculous
lengths to make it like just
overly ambitious like I mean I dare say
that this special is actually special
I'm so stoked for it yeah man and the
best part too is it's funny it's funny
like with or without the TVs with or
without like all the kind of bells and
whistles like it's so damn funny so this
is just icing on the cake I mean dude
and you have the same director like same
people are shooting it that did already
special so that's cool too right
um I've been working on this bucket list
show for
more than five years I mean that's
insane of course like during the
pandemic not a lot was was going on so
maybe call it three and a half but
I spent eight months just putting the
basic show together with the the first
vignettes and then I mean dude
it's just it's never stopped like the
the evolution the work on it kicking out
bits replacing them with new and better
ones like the videos get like changed
every night almost like with little tiny
things Jared how do you feel that it's
almost the end of The Bucket List tour
Bittersweet I mean there's there's just
about nowhere to go left with it I mean
granted we didn't do Europe and that
kind of is it kick in the nuts but um
it's time it's time and and I I feel so
so ready man so ready for this for this
taping
correction I'll be ready once I have a
nice smooth shave which I get from
Harry's these are the best shaving
products known to man five blade razor
top of the line and no gimmicks no
vibrating lights nothing you don't need
that people are paying way too much
money for it's everything that you do
need at the most reasonable prices plus
Harry's is hooking up the listeners of
the Wild Ride podcast with the craft
handle set this has the weighted
ergonomic craft handle the five blade
razor the travel cover to protect the
razor the foaming shave gel this is a
value of 17 but you guys the listeners
of the Wild Ride podcast get all of that
for just ten dollars it's an insane deal
and I swear to you these are the only
razors I shave with and that's been the
case for years now way before they
sponsored this pot cast I love Harry's
you will too jump on this deal by going
to harrys.com
Stevo yeah man and enjoy a nice clean
shave and catch mine on the special when
it comes out yeah dude let's get back to
it and then once that happens we've got
like what I what I call the Victory lap
we've got the one last run down the the
east coast in September and then it's on
to the next thing yeah and how's that
going to work like are you going to go
back to like clubs and like workout
material like because you're sort of a
different animal than most comedians
because you're like a multimedia thing
but you're planning to do something like
that that I mean the way that I did The
Bucket List was to first film The
vignette and then go to the comedy club
and just tell the story of that vignette
and so I put together piece by piece
when you go on stage at a comedy club in
La you typically get like a 10 minute
set maybe 20 but like 10 15 minutes sure
and and that would be my time to just
tell the story of one bit and then you
know I would like I would work that and
I'd work that like over without showing
the video without showing the video oh
no video oh so you just tell the story
you just got to make it funny even
without the payoff of seeing it right if
I was at the Hollywood improv I would be
able to show the video but if I was at
the comedy store or the Laugh Factory I
would not be able to show the video it's
better that you can't because like you
have to make it funny without it yeah
it's totally better that you can wow
that's cool and so that that that's
absolutely what I'll do with the next
one
um
but it's just it's again uh it's crazy
like whatever happens after this it's
it's one of two things that I'm gonna go
into
uh of course one being gone too far and
the other one like this is kind of uh
Mega Man who knows if it'll happen yeah
but uh whatever comes next it is so
high level that um it's just exciting
and I'm not like sad about going into it
I'm nervous because the bucket list is
so good but that's good for you that's
like the fear you need like yeah okay so
what else we're gonna talk about
um
the uh time here in London I I want to
say this because Knoxville like uh
always makes fun of me for being the guy
who will text his buddies his press you
know like like dude check out this rad
article written about me you know like
Knoxville would never do that and uh so
I really leaned into it because I got so
much press which article did you send
them
I sent him like from my publicist I get
like the Press clips and then there was
an additional hey here's additional uh
press clips from the Tower of London
Bridge jump and then there's a third
email get more additional that you sent
all those to Knoxville this list got so
ridiculously long I uh copied and pasted
the whole list and uh I sent it to
Knoxville uh saying congratulations for
your uh prank panel because the promos
just so great we saw it on the UFC like
I was like it looked great on the UFC
like way to go on the prank panel and
also check out how much press I just got
and
I don't mind sharing what he wrote back
because it's so funny he goes oh man
Steve oh man you know Stevo thank you so
much for compiling this list of 49 links
you saved me so much work
that's so great thank God and I just I
just love it man when when the cops
detained you after jumping off the
bridge what were they saying to you okay
the reality is that like when they put
me in the cop car like
it was largely an exercise in uh
protecting me from like the the crowd
that was gathering they just wanted some
privacy yeah to talk to me about like uh
their sensitivity which wasn't like a
loss being broken but rather the you
know people attempting to take their own
life by jumping off the bridge in
exactly the same spot that I had just
had they're like we really don't want I
don't see how cool How could somebody
take their life I know from that I guess
like the current sometimes like because
that there's a tide that comes up and
down in that River each day and
depending on when you jump there might
be a crazy current pulling you and like
pulling you under but like you got to be
a pretty bad swimmer yeah so perfectly
if that's the case because there was
nothing like that and twice mind you
because how many people have died on the
tower bridge can you look at that oh
yeah what happened to you the last time
you jumped off of it it was it was just
over 20 years ago almost exactly 20
years ago I I jumped off the bridge in
almost exactly the same spot did you die
okay did uh did you get in trouble no
but the cops were not waiting for I got
this guy I guess I got out of the water
quicker or maybe like people just didn't
notice as much did you get up in the
same spot I got but I was right in the
same spot it was that same gate locked
okay I was able to just get right out of
there yeah and uh yeah that was funny
you walked like into a cage immediately
you were already behind bars as soon as
you got out of the Water Tower of London
Town no no no no no no that'll be like
all kinds of do um tower bridge and then
the s word which there you go
man that's sad I I don't think you can
even say like killed or died anymore
it's unalived
himself that's what I want to talk about
like uh all these things that are not
okay to say anymore like cockpit
cutting down an airplane it's no longer
a cockpit they don't want to use the
word cockpit they remember the other day
we laughed so hard because I asked a
photographer to to bring a slave flash
yeah and as Paul says you could still
say that yeah I was like we're not
saying master bedroom but we're still
saying slave flag I don't know how long
that's gonna last right and uh and then
what's this you're saying that uh you
they did that I don't I don't know I
don't know how true this is or whatever
but I've seen it in a few in a few spots
online but you can no longer say vagina
or [__] you have to say bonus hole Yeah
that's that but it's just fun to say
like oh you hear what they're upset
about now so it's like if one person
gets upset it becomes like national news
because your battery's gonna die I'm
pretty sure that bonus hole is not the
new term I like it I mean I kind of wish
it is and then didn't you just say
there's another one
a bunch can you type in words that are
uh yeah canceled uh and like Politically
Incorrect yeah canceled words yeah
that's good words you can't say on
YouTube here we go
I know I think it's like misogynistic
words
all right I I thought that was going to
be a lot more fun to talk about than it
was but uh
bonus hole is a good one
never mind I think we [__] up yeah but
yeah I feel like we always get up in
arms it's like oh you hear they're upset
at Beyonce for like saying whatever you
know saying like uh spaz but I bet only
just 100 people got upset but everyone
else got upset that anyone was upset and
like that's the big talking point like
you hear they're upset yeah those people
were more upset than the people yeah
exactly
um
what uh
bubbly perky let's go to the comments
moist everyone always has a problem with
moist it's like not even that bad of a
word yeah it's not some people are like
wow people just go like I can't even
hear that word
has he has always been is always
referred to women
although the word has he has always
referred to women it's the change in
connotation over time that makes it
problematic today originally Hussey was
a neutral term used to describe a female
head of the household this makes sense
given that it is deformed all right I
got an interesting fact do you know
where uh this may or may not be true
maybe we can look it up but uh do you
know where fake eyelashes came from uh
no it's a 1920s term that like hookers
used to put fake eyelashes on because
they're called umbrellas
so that was you're saying that was what
they were originally called yeah was it
umbrella they were four come to get out
of your eyes
yeah uh but yeah just because you can
call the eyebrows
umbrella doesn't mean
that doesn't mean fake eyelashes were
invented to catch
who invented fake eyelashes and why
probably because it's stylish have big
eyelashes so girls wanted big ones just
because you can call
[Applause]
that's really funny man
we should do like a mock trial and you
have to be a lawyer and like argue a
case it'd be really no no go to the net
go be go back and then go down one did
prostitutes invent fake eyelashes
I mean maybe they did because it's like
it's it's
too not to be a guy
first of all close your eyes if
someone's coming on your face like
excuse me what do you need like uh yeah
well look at that that's false well okay
we proved me wrong yeah 18.
okay but yeah in 1882 London prostitute
Gerda parido parietal invented
elongating eyelashes or
umbrellas to block semen so you saw that
I didn't see that exact one I saw other
people like make videos about it okay
like I mean I might have to bleep some
of that I think that this this is uh
gonna be a
problematic upload what about the movie
that just came out this uh last weekend
what's it called the sound of Freedom
yeah has anybody seen that no no I think
it just came out in theaters is it
documentary or it's a movie so Scott was
trying to tell me that this movie uh
outperformed Indiana Jones on the first
weekend but on Indiana Jones's first
weekend both they came out the same day
so just show us like the box office
from the other day or whatever but the
second weekend it didn't that's what I
heard on the pbd podcast
so what's it what's it about I mean just
it's about it's a true story it's a true
story on child trafficking this one guy
I guess played by the Jim cavas cavazole
is that how you say it caviesel is uh
the real life guy who did this and you'd
go down and and try to rescue these kids
that are Jim Caviezel really did this
and then they made a movie better oh he
plays the guy he plays the guy Jim
caviezo played Jesus in The Passion of
the Christ yeah is this a Mel Gibson
movie I think so because I saw him
promoted on Dana White's yeah is that
why Mel Gibson was at the fights
probably he goes to fights anyway right
yeah I've seen him at the fights
we should get mail on here
when I look at him he kind of reminds me
of bam
really he could be a cousin the gray
goatee malmar Jerry yeah oh my God yeah
bring up some images well they both have
the three letter words
yeah for sure
to see him talk too
yeah [__] dude I finally saw Apocalypto
so good it's so good like a couple weeks
ago it's a Mel Gibson directed movie and
it's like it's not even in English the
whole thing is subtitled it's like one
of the best movies of all time yeah it's
so good why is it so good it's like
about just like the capturing Native
Americans yeah
these different tribes like battling
each other for dominance and it's just
it's just so it's just non-stop that's
what happens yeah it's I I highly
recommend it wow and you got to read the
whole thing you gotta read the whole
thing and you don't even mind and it's
kind of brilliant because yeah they can
do it in any country in any language
because you just gotta change the
subtitles
um yeah and maybe if they were speaking
in English it wouldn't like ring true
well sure I think they're speaking like
quechua or something what was that there
was another movie that was really good
that you had to read about like uh
Brazilian oh city of God city of God
yeah yeah
yeah city of God was good my favorite
movie on Netflix of all time is
Headhunters and that's all Norwegian
um in in English subtitles
yeah I mean some of the best movies are
subtitled with a parasite was subtitled
yeah so what's going on with movies man
like uh that's Herbie Hancock in the
Headhunters I don't know Headhunter yeah
with that dude on the uh Jamie Lannister
our superhero movies still just crushing
it so much but they suck they they're
always gonna crush it I feel like I feel
like those are I feel like those are the
only movies that should be at a movie
theater anymore right like I would
rather watch movies in the privacy of my
own house
yeah but like
when's the last time you've been to a
movie theater uh it's been a long time
recently I just saw the new Wes Anderson
movie at movie theater and it was
awesome oh was that good yeah yeah
asteroid City but I feel like ever since
that last Avengers movie it's kind of
been a downhill for these it's like that
was the peak of like the superhero
excitement and now we're just kind of
coasting and writing it out I mean I
just feel like movies in general that
are coming out nowadays are just trash
the last movie I saw in the theaters was
jackass
yeah I saw John Wick if like a month ago
was the worst thing I've ever seen in my
life John Wick movies aren't good the
first one was pretty good I don't think
they're good they're like just kind of
sappy action movies what's your favorite
movie of all time
uh that's what I could tell a lot about
a man I mean I
like when you ask me that the Life
Aquatic was Steve sissu comes to mind
the Wes Anderson movie did you see
anything and everything all at once that
was really good yeah
that's like the came out recently on
metaphysical everything everywhere all
at once oh that's the one about uh
Stephen Hawking
no no no no no no it's um it's with that
girl from Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
the editing is unbelievable it's just
really I couldn't get into clever really
creative movie it's about like multiple
realities and [__] really Curtis is in
it yeah and she plays like a gnarly
Jamie Lee Curtis back in the day what a
nug oh man what a nut and that scene in
uh Trading Places Trading Places dead
anytime she's in workout equipment
a recent picture of Johnny Knoxville
next to a recent picture of Jamie Lee
Curtis and it was really it was really
pretty yeah
yeah
Steve what's your favorite movies is it
still Harold and mod I've watched Harold
and mod at this point too many times to
like enjoy watching again but this is
kind of random and I wouldn't say
overall the greatest movie but but the
movie I
walked out of the movie theater and said
man that was a good movie
I know what it is war dogs with Jonah
Hill it's a good movie and Miles that
was good it was great okay another let's
just say that's like one of your
favorite movies that's that's crazy I I
feel like you're gonna say the the
imitation game the imitation that was my
next one I was gonna say imitation game
was fantastic that's where they cracked
the now touring code yeah that was good
that was really good that was
unbelievable it was unbelievable it did
Keira Knightley
she's in the imitation game nug
nuggets was actually like incredible you
didn't think it was like No what else
was good but if you're asking somebody
what's their favorite movie you're gonna
throw that in the top ten I just
remember I remember the rest of the
night after watching War Dogs it's a
great movie it's so good yeah I remember
feeling that uh after I watched um the
Facebook maybe the social network
thinking man that was really good that
was a good movie yeah do you have a
favorite documentary or like a a Bible
pick of all time yeah you're a big True
Crime what's your number one okay that
the best programming
don't [__] with cats on Netflix I
couldn't get into it oh my God you just
dude
it's the best
you got it I've never seen it it's so
well done it's like unbelievable I don't
know how you could not get into it like
uh it's
unbelievable I feel like that and the
Jinx are kind of the gold standard okay
he's pretty good all right then let me
ask you do you Steve do you have a
favorite podcast you listen to do you
listen to any podcast ah I feel like
yeah I don't really like podcasts are
for losers
yeah what's your go-to YouTube channel
JCS I I love Jason yes I love stay awake
yeah um
what else uh yeah there's a bunch that
creeping they're beyond evil is really
good
I don't know that one
um
the red tree crime yeah that's good I
mean those are all the like JCS inspired
right content right but they have enough
self-respect to not just call themselves
JC Essence yeah that's true that's true
and they upload more often a JCS drop is
like oh my God it's like a new Dr Dre
album
you only get a few and they're so good
yeah I mean JCS is literally the Quentin
Tarantino of YouTube yeah he should do
like a HBO show or something like right
he should
you guys should produce it right you
know and and for mentioning JCS on the
podcast I
um
got tweeted at by JCS they're like oh
man thanks for shouting us out that's
sick why don't you go on his channel and
do something or I mean dude like that's
the thing is that we we have nothing to
offer each other in each other's content
yeah have them over for dinner dinner
party I did I'd be fascinated and it's
not one person I don't think I think
it's like a whole team of people oh yeah
like JCS stands for Jim can't swim best
YouTube channel on YouTube does it stand
for Jim can't swim I thought it was like
it's chance for Jim can't swim there you
go Jim can you do your research I mean
Dan I love it it's my it's my favorite
all right Steve let me ask you your take
on this and I know Paul's take and I
know Vinnie's take but
um when you and Lux get married is she
gonna keep her last name is she going to
change her last name it's gonna be two
last names
I'm curious what your have you thought
that far have you guys talked about it
um
Lux Glover
it would be a two last name situation
really but Lux right Glover so the
woman's name goes first uh her name is
just cooler
like Glover I've never been stoked on my
last name Glover Danny Glover I get it
again
just for me and I was never stoked on my
life you've always been stoked in your
middle name Gilchrist
gilchris
my sister used to know that she'd call
me Gilly and I would cry
you know what's your sister's middle
name is it something English ah Cynthia
Claire
Claire's pretty English can't do much
but yeah I always felt weird about my
last name too like risky it always feels
like I hate typing like when I buy
flights
or two k's is there 1K yeah people spell
it wrong everywhere my mom's middle name
was gay Donna gay Glover that's pretty
good her birth name was Donna gay
watheir huh that's kind of sick yeah
yeah
it's kind of sick how you doing Benny
I'm chilling Dude any news
how are you recovering from uh us
blasting you about your girl getting
blasted
dude I'm cool with it yeah all right
yeah I'm cool with it good yeah you're a
confident guy yeah I'm confident uh I
look at you were in a robe yeah we're in
your hotel room and he's been kind of
blowing up these days popping off like
on tour we've we've uh created a new
pre-show which heavily features me and
his new skinny Vinny t-shirt which can
be purchased at the merch table and at
www.skinny vinnie.tv is that driving
traffic that is no but you can drive
traffic to that just not to like it's
his website to buy America why can't you
drive traffic to like sexual things oh I
forgot I took them off because I have
all the shirts I have all the shirts
with me yeah you took them all off you
brought everything you had yeah have you
fulfilled all the orders the people that
bought it look at you dude and I got
that Wick [__] taken care of good yeah
there you go skinny baby I'm so proud of
you you're killing it dude thanks dude
dude the the love that I've been getting
at the venues has been pretty surreal
we believe that you appreciate it
[Music]
is that you want to be famous
give it to me yeah you're dying like
Isaac sends me like if you'll send me a
photo like uh of you
just hey I'm just gonna go check out the
merch line you know just see what's up
and it's just you like posting up just
trying to get recognized but by the
merge line
wait what
yeah yeah yeah
if people are taking photos with you
after the show yeah yeah you'll just put
yourself in the spot where maybe you
like it yeah I shy away from it getting
noticed it's awesome In fairness I used
to do the same thing after I would open
I would always go to the merch table at
the end of the show just be like you
guys good need anything
I love that now at the shows you're so
heavily featured in the pre-show yeah
getting so much shine I tell people and
appreciate it go say what's up to you at
the merch table yeah I love it I want
you to blow up I want you to just why do
you want to be famous is there different
reasons for everybody wanting Fame uh to
get back at somebody for making fun of
you no I don't think it's anything like
that I don't know I think I've just
always been so intrigued and fascinated
in Fame and
maybe it had something to do with my up
my upbringing but I don't know I just I
mean Steve you're got Fitness you wanted
to be famous for attention that's I
wanted to live forever yeah Paul why do
you why do you want to be famous
well okay it feels good
that's really the thing but for me it's
like Fame is not my my highest goal it's
like I want to be like a uh someone who
like makes music so if if I'm making
music and I'm successful at that a
symptom of that is like Fame so it's
like I'm not like I just want to be
famous it's like I want to be known for
the [__] I'm doing but but I do enjoy
being recognized and like it just feels
good it's just kind of nice you feel
popular it's like being popular it feels
good that's really yeah I mean I feel
like Steve you said that like Fame is
like one of the most intoxicating drugs
sure
um I'm already thinking about what the
title for this podcast should be and uh
Stevo got questioned for a double murder
for sure that's what came to my mind
well that that'd be probably good for a
clip but uh I mean the the whole dynamic
of uh you know
adam22 versus Jonah Hill who took the L
that's that's great yeah I like that
yeah because that's where we started off
talking about yeah like uh it's topical
you know like in Jonah Hill is in the
news for being exactly the opposite of
what Adam 22 is in the news for yes
they're both catching heat who caught
the L
strip I like it maybe they both did yeah
it's a spectrum yeah I I submit that
Jonah Hill like off his back
office back to Jonah Hill like was
perfect he was even courteous in in
those texts I think it's kind of a kook
but
he cures [__] to be like don't I don't
want you hanging out with me so angry
you know I was trying to get him on the
podcast
when there's a guess I'm not there so
I just think it's weird it's weird
Behavior I don't think it's like
cancelable I don't think like I'm not
mad at him it would be weird if your
chick your fiance went to lunch with
another dude would not bother me and
it's even more weirder that it doesn't
bother you at all maybe that's unusual I
get that but to me that if she was like
I met this like this I got this buddy we
work with we've got lunch like we eat
lunch three times a week
like what is the negative to me if she's
getting lunch with somebody I I asked
okay so out of four of us three think
you're wrong that's fine
you're out of your goddamn mind what is
the negative what is the negative to you
if she's getting lunch I think it's just
inappropriate like because like she
wouldn't want you doing that to her
let's see let's say like a group of
people goes out to lunch it's the
one-on-one piece dude because somebody
always has feelings like I got friend
zoned and I like started getting
feelings somebody will always get
feelings in in like a friendly
relationship where it's guy and a girl
if they're like heterosexual yeah I'm
just saying it doesn't bother me I don't
know that I'm I'm not saying I'm right
or everyone should feel the way I feel
but it would not bother me at all if the
guy had was attracted to your fiance
would you still let them not let them
but like would you be okay with them
if he was like dude like she's like he
kind of likes me
yeah I mean if she's not going to do
anything with him so but he likes her
then that's going to suck for him not
for me
all right okay you've said your piece
I've said my piece that's my piece sorry
Jonah well this was a definitely new
approach to the Wild Ride podcast I like
it
um I'm nervous about it like anybody
who's still listening to this like uh
give us some love man because we never
like it's our first time being like
let's talk current events yeah we've
never given our opinion really on [__]
right you know what I mean yeah yeah I
think it's more of our personalities
we're coming to light yeah I know that
people say hey man we want to get to
know you guys want to be hanging out
with you guys
love having Paul Briskey in the mix
I've got a lot of comments saying they
they love these kind of podcasts yeah
the last No guest podcast we did yeah
but like think about it two years down
the road or a year down the road the
more you do these you build like these
people that aren't just showing up
because Bam's on the show or Johnny
Knoxville's on the show it's like I love
these guys I want to talk to them right
I want to hang out with them every week
so and there's always putting that time
in it's like an investment and people
like the people that watch it the
comments are overwhelmingly positive on
that last one and I like having you on
thank you because you're like a level
like uh I'm one end Steve's 1n Vinnie's
one end and you're I feel like you're
like even Keel on most things like it
you're a good sounding board to bounce
things off of oh my god dude it could be
the best like pop risky like I've said
it a million times the the just has me
by the balls the most like Irreplaceable
most unbelievably talented good creative
force on my team yeah because I because
I can be like Steve you probably
shouldn't do that and you're like
that's going on my Instagram
I love you guys man I appreciate that
yeah yeah I feel like I could be like
Steve do that maybe don't do that he's
like no I'm absolutely gonna do that
it's like Paul you know we like and
you're like well I think it works I mean
we do it you know yeah I don't know yeah
thank you for saying that and yeah I
love I love being here I mean being on
the on the podcast with you guys is
super fun [__] love it well hopefully
we can build up uh the podcasts that
have no guests if you can you know I
would love to to do it more there's
plenty of stuff I'd love to talk about
and if current events is is uh gonna
resonate
like
and and by the way too I want to say
this is just one final thought it's not
just because I think it'd be great to
have Jonah Hill in the podcast
um I genuinely don't think he did [__]
wrong I read his text and and I I have
no issue with it he's just got you know
like it's it's those texts were written
like somebody who's had a bad experience
before and just doesn't [__] around with
that [__] but can I look at why is she
screenshotting and like sending it out
that's the cook piece because it's not
like that's kooky too like to publicly
like try to bring someone down is
kookier than Jonah I do agree with no
I'm genuinely asking is is there a
reason why like she did that is she like
to spite him maybe or just like it was
too assassinate his character to to
compromise his livelihood she was trying
to bring him down she's a bad person
Jonah Hill just did that uh documentary
on him and his therapist right so I feel
like everything that like he wrote her
was in consultation he probably was
going through it with that guy it was
like I made like it was written like a
guy who's been working on himself yeah
who's had issues in the past and just
like he said setting boundaries and then
she'd post it like oh the wrong use of
the word boundaries
[__] off
yeah I mean everybody I've seen that's
like talked about it is kind of talk
like exactly what we're thinking it's
like well what did you do wrong and I
think that's the consensus for the
record I do agree she's kookier for like
making this whole thing of it yeah
I'm a fence sitter she's the worst all
right everybody we love you and thank
you for sticking around
right you kidding me man was that
gossiping enough we were like a bunch of
old hags just talking about everybody in
town and we had fun and I really really
hope that you guys enjoyed it too
because man it felt fresh felt new Paul
did you put uh like a bunch of assets on
the YouTube screen cool man yeah I mean
we kind of took a page out of Rogan's
book with that one and it felt good
so if you liked it let us know man that
would mean a lot and as always you know
I love you and dude wish me luck
it's uh it's not tomorrow night but as
you listen to this it is
man I'm ready awesome guys I love you
ah